welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee meeting
i am councillor keith welland and i'm
chairing the meeting today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons in the
chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or if you are
unable to do so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please don't interrupt other speakers if
you are attending the meeting to speak
and you persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones
are on silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and the
press are not lawfully excluded
so i'll just ask beth to tell tell you
all who is who's attending today
thank you chair we have simon clifton
chief officer for citizens advice with
suffolk colleen sweeney chief officer
for sudbury and district citizens advice
and we have rooster emerson communities
officer grant and funding practitioner
we also have councillor julie flatman
cabinet member for communities in
mid-suffolk thank you very much
sorry beth can you just repeat that
it wasn't very clear actually sorry
we have simon clifton the chief officer
of asset and citizens advice in mid
suffolk colleen sweeney chief
chief officer for sovereign districts
citizens advice
royston emerson the community's officer
grant and funding practitioner and we
have councillor julie flatman cabinet
member for communities
thank you
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
please
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor paul kenyon councillor
terence carter councillor catherine
brandon and councillor jane gould and
councillor john field is substituting
for council carter
thank you very much
are there any declarations of pecuniary
and non-pecuniary interest by members
we have one council muller
yes i am a member of the citizens of ice
mid-suffolk trustee board
thank you very much
are there any other
cancer scarf
citizens advice is one of my two
charities but i don't think that
inhibits my contribution to the
conversation
thank you
um we now turn to the minutes
can we confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 22nd of november
2021
are there any points regarding regarding
the accuracy of the minutes
there are none
can i have a proposal please that we
accept the minutes we have a proposal
uh councillor caston seconded by
councillor muller
the governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress in the modern duck
has everyone voted have they all come
through
yep that is seven votes four and one
abstention thank you very much
are there any
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme please
received thank you very much
any questions by the public
none received thank you very much
questions by councillors
none received thank you
we turn to the forthcoming decisions
list
do members have any comments on the
forthcoming decisions list please
no there are none thank you the
forthcoming decisions list is for noting
so we now move on to item jos 2120
which is a review of local citizens
advice
and so i would like to invite
our two representatives from our local
citizens advice
simon clifton and colleen sweeney to
give to give their presentation please
good morning everybody
um by way of reminder for those who were
present at our last joint scrutiny
presentation
and to inform those who were not i would
like to speak briefly about who we are
and what we do
as you will know we can all face
problems that seem complicated or
intimidating
at citizens advice we believe no one
should have to face these problems
without good quality independent advice
we give people the knowledge and
confidence to find their way forward
whoever they are and whatever their
problem
so when we say whoever you are
we do not place any limits on number of
visits a client makes
we do not restrict it to any particular
beneficiary group
anyone can come and see us for advice
we do not judge people who come to us
for help
and when we say whatever your problem
we give advice on an extensive range of
areas
and we work with partners whenever
people need further specifics
sorry specific support or more
specialist input that we do not have
what do we mean by find a way forward
we do not make decisions for our clients
we present options and empower them to
act
or assist further when the client is
considered to have need for more
in-depth support
we match the support we give to clients
needs
so we do have clients who just need us
to point them in the right direction
and we have other clients who need more
support
it's the case of assessing how confident
each person is and the right approach
for them
so we were asked to
present to the community today about how
we've had to transform our service
through the pandemic
so like many organizations we've had to
adapt how we've delivered our advice and
support rapidly
pre-pandemic the majority of our clients
were seen face to face and with that
option removed we had to consider how we
could best help clients while still
ensuring that we were able to operate
safely
so in mid-south we implemented a
five-stage plan for the delivery of vice
we were fortunate they were able to draw
on a tabletop exercise that we carried
out um two weeks before the first
lockdown which allowed us to look at our
business continuity
however even with that experience we
initially had issues in sourcing remote
work and equipment which ultimately led
us to develop a business model that
allowed us to
continue to deliver advice from our
advice centre
the demographic our workforce
particularly our volunteers meant that
we lost over 50 percent overnight as
they were required to shield at the very
time when we faced increased demand
we redeployed staff from other roles and
was fortunate that the remaining
volunteers not shielding increased the
number of sessions that they were
available
once equipment and in our case telephony
support became more available we were
able to utilize staff who were shielding
in a remote business model to support
our core services that were providing
from our advice centre
we were also early adopters of virtual
advice and gained valuable experience
and knowledge on what worked and what
did not when we used this particular
contact model
through the pandemic we have moved
through the different stages within our
plan up and down the various levels of
service provision following the guidance
in place at that time as i'm sure
everyone will realize that is never more
important than now
we
operate in a cove insecure workplace
environment and as of today we are at
stage four
which is telephone email virtual advice
face to face by appointment but we are
not offering a dropping advice service
the largest plant contact channel
is now telephone followed by email
the pandemic has provided us with the
opportunity to improve and develop our
advice by these channels
a number of our volunteer advisors left
our organisation during the pandemic
period but we've also had new joiners
and we're pleased to they would report
potential volunteer numbers have
recently increased
what has definitely benefited our
organisation was the initial decision to
keep the advice center open for staff
and volunteers as we've not had any
issues with people being anxious or
unwilling to return to our workplace
in mid-suffolk we had hoped that in the
new year kovid would move from a
pandemic to endemic but recent events to
appear to best delayed that decision
once once it's clear that kovid is being
treated as endemic within society is our
intention to move to stage five
which is a return to pre-pandemic
service model colleen
some of my presentations remain dry so i
shall continue so i've spilled some
water
okay so we've had a very similar set up
in sudbury although we did close the
office during both periods of lockdown
telephones and email became the only
route for contact with clients
our staff and volunteers adapted very
quickly to the new way of working
and we too became much better at
delivering telephone advice
we didn't see many losses to adviser
numbers in the first year but sadly lost
many as we moved into the second year
and people became more despondent
i am pleased to report that we now have
all our staff and most of our volunteers
back in our offices although we are
going forward with a new way of working
we have realized the value of retaining
a mix of home and not office working for
staff where roles allow
this has proven productive productive
with regards to time management and
saves death space at a time of expansion
for our volunteers we are now we now
understand the value of having a team
working remotely delivering telephone
advice at a time where we've also
realized the value of maintaining the
level of telephone advice that we can
now manage
we are currently investigating how we
can join in with the option of digital
hubs
over the past months we have
reintroduced face-to-face interviews for
those clients who need the most
these are by by appointment rather than
drop in and have opened the opportunity
to those clients who had not been able
to access our service for so long
i have made the decision not to close
our office in respect of the
government's recent guidance on working
at home if possible
but have instead given the option to
staff and volunteers to do so if they
feel they need to
all have decided to continue to come in
i consider us to have become even more
of an essential service
than we have ever been before
and this shows in our statistics
to lock down again at this point would
jeopardize the massive steps that we
have taken
to get back to where we were before this
all began
we can see the demand growing by week at
present
so this slide that we've now got up on
the screen uh demonstrates how our
service has transformed um and that's in
primarily our contact channels with our
clients
so it shows it how in the way in which
we contact our clients has changed post
march 2020
pre-march 2020 client contacts by
telephone and face-to-face were broadly
similar
however following the first lockdown
this changed dramatically as
restrictions prevented people from being
seen face to face leading to a rapid
rise in telephone advice that continues
to this day
additionally email contacts increased
post march 2020 which in part was due to
the change in our client demographic
which we found to be more digitally
literate
and wanting to use this channel as their
primary contact
as can be seen on this chart email
contact remains the second largest after
telephone and we do not expect this
trend to change even when all guidance
and restrictions are removed
the blue line on the chart
represents in-person contacts and as you
will see that it's showing a gradual
increase from august 2021 onwards
as colleen said we do continue to see
clients who require face-to-face advice
and these are generally those who are
vulnerable and require complex case work
client demand
is something that's very very difficult
for any of us to sort of
project
but this chart here shows
20 20 21
and year to date the end of november
and the best forecast we have is that we
will be seeing
approximately the same number of people
as we did
in 2020-2021
20-21
and april to the end of october 21-22
there have been several changes to our
client demographics
we have seen a pronounced trend of
seeing more younger people
we're seeing more in their 20s and 30s
and believe this is due to this client
group favoring better access to phone
advice and the impact that kovid has had
on their lives
we tended to see fewer people in the
older age groups in the pandemic year
but we're now seeing people in their 70s
and 80s coming back
this is likely due to the reopening of
face-to-face sessions but could have
also been impacted by a recent increase
in energy advice
another change worth mentioning is that
we've seen a higher percentage of
inquiries from female clients than usual
where there's always been a pretty even
split
we now have 63 percent of clients
presenting as female
although we have always had around 50 of
our clients presenting as disabled or
suffering from a long-term health
condition
there has been a rise in this client
group too
with over 50
now falling into this category
next slide
so the citizen's advice that we're very
fortunate that we are able to draw an
awful lot of client data
so this is a heat map of the location of
clients with the mid-suffolk postcode
from march 2020 to april 21
the yellow areas indicate
greater numbers of clients
across the district and you will see
that they are mainly in the three urban
settings of stone market needham market
and elmswell
however the map also demonstrates that
we are helping clients across the entire
district but know we have to do more to
improve our accessibility
in august 2021 we open an outreach
advice service i library for one morning
a week the opening of this outreach had
been delayed by the pandemic
restrictions in place until that time
prior to the pandemic dis and thetford
citizens advise had provided an outreach
service at the health centre but a
decision was made to withdraw from
suffolk
up to 10th december 221 we have seen 30
clients at this outreach and it's very
clear that our services are needed at
this location as there is a clear need
the types of issues seen have included
help with housing energy welfare
benefits relationships and debt we will
continue to live this service but
outreach advice is not a low-cost
delivery option
we've been working hard to develop our
virtual advice contact channel working
in partnership with wattage and flying
station welfare team we have provided a
laptop for service personnel their
families to speak to us by virtual
appointments
the welfare team identify those that
need advice and facilitate the
appointment of their offices where the
client can speak to one of our trained
advisors by video conference
we also have a partnership with needham
market town council and provided a
tablet device for use for local
residents to contact us again via video
conference
we hope in the new year that we'll be
able to locate the tablet in the new
library
to improve accessibility
admits i've
been working closely with the district's
customer operations team to co-develop
virtual contact points across the
district
this work is ongoing and we would hope
to have more devices in place across the
districts by quarter one of next year
that could not only be used by sitting's
advice by other partners including
district officers and other strategic
bodies
as you can see from the baby district
map we are fully aware of the need to
reopen our outreach in hadley
and we are now in a position to do so
from the 20th of january next year
the digital hub projects that have
become available to mid suffolk clients
are of great value
we are looking way of ways of joining in
to allow us to make this offer available
to baber clients too
it will ensure for us at sudbury that we
are covering our more rural areas
and shortly and holbrook with more than
just the email and telephone advice
so this chart demonstrates client demand
for universal credit
it shows the increase in number of
people claiming universal credit post
march 2020 when the first lockdown was
announced
as you can see
the increase in numbers claiming were
very rapid and have been sustained
the next chart will provide some more
detail on why this may be
this chart relates to the mid-suffolk
district
the yellow line shows people searching
for work that spiked in may 2020 and
started to go down in about april 2021
the blue line is people who are in work
and still on universal credit
this went up in may june 2020 and had
stayed high
why is this
in mid-suffolk 16 of those in employment
are self-employed
this is the highest of any district in
suffolk and nearly double that at the
next nearest district
legacy benefits such as working tax
credits child tax credits housing
benefit job seekers allowance employment
support allowance and income support
but probably all a lot of these have
been replaced by people having to make
application for universal credit because
these replace legacy benefits when
people move from them to universal
credit
the claimant does not always have the
option to return to the legacy benefit
which might be a reason why some of the
supply the
amount still on universal credit remains
high
it also might be that some of the people
who found work are still on universal
credit
or they were self-employed and their
income hasn't come back to what it was
before the pandemic
the purple line
are for people who have no work related
requirements as they are too sick to
work and that has shown a steady upward
trend
this is significant the reasons for this
could include there are more people who
are too sick to work or that more people
have moved from the employment support
allowance legacy benefit onto universal
credit
in may 2020 16 had no work related
requirements that means two work to sick
so sorry too sick to work but this
increased to twenty four percent by
october twenty one
the yellow line shows that in
mid-suffolk in may twenty twenty forty
of the people who were on a universal
credit were searching for work
by october 2021 the percentage searching
for work had decreased 26 showing more
people had returned to employment and
were no longer claiming universal credit
the green line along the bottom
are people who are too sick to work but
can do some work related activity and as
you will see that has remained fairly
steady
the issue of legacy benefits will
continue to cloud the data
as the 1609 people on the employment
support allowance as of may 2021
most of whom have no work-related
requirements will eventually move to
universal credit so that line
is going to
roughly double
we are also where there are
approximately 2 000 families on tax
credits to move over as well
so as you can see it's a similar picture
in babra
although the number searching for work
hasn't gone down as much
in may 2020
40 of people who were on universal
credit were searching for work
and 18 had no work related requirements
these are people who are too sick for
work
by
october 2021
31 were searching for work
and 25 had no work-related requirements
there are around 1 600 people still on
tax credits
and
1435 still on employment and support
slide please
this table shows you the total issues in
each area for april to march 2019 to 20
and 20-21
and april to november
21-22
so the issues in
21-22 are much lower because it
represents part of the year
but the percentages are what is
important
please
we had holds on action with regards to
debt
and we've seen very little demand for
debt advice throughout the pandemic
but as predicted
can now see a steady increase in its
return
at mid-suffolk and sudbury we have taken
steps to ensure that we can meet this
demand by increasing our capacity
both now have an additional full-time
debt advisor
as we took advantage of a one-year train
uh training funding part from the money
and pension service which allowed us to
each train a new person throughout that
year
next slide please
an immediate and steady increase in
demand for employment advice has now
settled down
we are seeing what what is more like the
usual numbers now
next slide
we have seen a steady increase in
requests for food bank and charitable
support issues
with an average of 54 food bank and
charitable support issues per month
in 2009
20
increasing to an average of 82 in 2021
and an average of 148 so far in 2122.
next
the use of food banks has increased
dramatically during the pandemic
often used as an economic barometer
the increased demand is clearly linked
to the impact of the pandemic on
individuals and families
and shows no signs of decreasing
across the entire year we have referred
over 50 percent more clients for a food
parcel
as you will be aware many of the food
banks have reported even larger
increases which is possibly as we're not
the only referral agency
through our holistic advice model
clients requesting a food parcel will
also be provided with help and support
to tackle other issues
such as the claimant of rights
entitlements
debt housing and employment etc
in sudbury from june this year
we have been able to offer supermarket
vouchers to our client
through government-covered
hardship and household support fund
grants
and will have distributed a total of ten
thousand pounds to those most in need by
the end of march twenty two
we have distributed between fifty and
two hundred pound to clients depending
on household size
having this practical offer has been of
amazing value
we're often asked what
impact do we
give for the money we receive
and as we're part of a national network
of citizens advice that we have a
financial modeling tool that we're able
to draw on that's only happened just
quite recently so what this chart shows
is this this is combined figures for
sudbury mid-suffolk but separately
both offices have said have
circulated our impact report to district
councillors
as you can see the economic benefit we
provide for every pound invested in us
demonstrates savings made to statutory
authorities our value for money and the
wider social benefits that our services
provide for our communities
our organizations rely very heavily on
our volunteer workforce to help us
deliver our quality advice services to
communities
what this chart shows the decline of our
volunteer numbers across our
organizations which has increased the
pressure on those that remain
however we have continued to deliver
advice and support to those most in need
even with this reduced capacity
as we previously said a number of
volunteer advisors decided after
shielding that they did not wish to
return
recruiting replacements has proved very
challenging during the pandemic where
competition for volunteers was high and
training new advisors very difficult to
the restrictions in place
this trend was worrying as the only
other option for our organizations would
be to employ paid staff to replace those
volunteer hours and the costs would be
unaffordable
118 000 pounds per annum for mid suffolk
and 103 500 pounds for sudbury district
however at this point i would stress
that volunteers are not a free resource
but they're a lower cost resource
than using paid staff
we undertaken targeted recruitment
campaigns using social media radio
interviews media articles and local
publications
we are pleased to report that we have
seen an increase in numbers content us
to inquire about volunteering and had to
increase our training resources to meet
that training need
for mid-suffolk we have recruited two
new trustees and are currently training
seven people to become generalist
advisors additionally we have five more
expressions of interest that are
following up and hope to get them into
our training program
sudbury are 12 do training advisors in
their training program and have
recruited three new trustees
delivery of training program remains a
challenge within the current and
changing covi guidance
one of the ways that we address need is
through the delivery of projects that
also diversify our funding streams
unfortunately beam projects the funding
cannot be guaranteed and the help to
claim service for universal credit and
debt advice funded by money advice
pensioners have currently just been
recommissioned
and they are both are likely to move to
a remote advice model as the tenders are
still alive we cannot say two more than
that much more than that other than that
both mid-south and sudbury will not be
part of the delivery of those
projects going forward
as we did we didn't meet the criteria
however there is no doubt that we will
still see clients who need help with
welfare benefits including universe
credit and those who are in debt
we both have established welfare
benefits advice services and committed
to providing debt advice that can be
accessed locally in sudbury
we have been successful in securing
lottery funding for debt advice for the
next three years in mid-suffolk a
full-time money advisor has been
recruited to work alongside our existing
provision funded by corps and reserves
this money advisor has also been given
the added responsibility of being a
housing single point of contact for the
district housing team in mid-suffolk
we are continually looking for other
opportunities to secure funding in the
new year we're working with the customer
operations team at the district house
and other partners to prepare a lottery
bid for the delivery of virtual advice
across the districts
[Applause]
have previously shared our concerns
about the lack of an integrated system
to support those in need across the
districts
this leads to duplication and does not
support proactive activities that break
cycles of inequality and need
we can report that following a meeting
with the new assistant director health
and wellbeing these concerns have been
shared and we have a shared ambition
to work with the district councils to
co-develop integrated systems of work as
equal partners
so what does that mean
we have worked with the district council
to explain the benefits of the suffolk
information partnership warm handover
scheme and both join the scheme this
year
this allows the sharing of information
and personal data between statutory
bodies and the charitable sector to
better support clients address their
issues
we are currently working with the
customer operations team and housing
team to share best practice and to agree
some joint working arrangements that
will help us provide a more integrated
system for residents in need
these include referrals from food banks
energy costs budgeting and debt
management
council tax and rent arrears
we have identified that there is no
single view of debt across the
authorities for council tax and rent
arrears
this leads to enforcement with counts
this leads to different enforcement of
the council tax
leading ultimately to liability orders
enforced by court enforcement officers
and rent arrears normally dealt with by
repayment plans where possible
however neither part of the process is a
view of the overall debt owed by the
individual that leads to confusion and
hardship
it is not unusual for a vulnerable
person to have 30 reduction from their
universal credit payments for rent
council tech or housing housing benefit
that's 30 percent just over 300 pounds
having raises an issue
the district council
teams have committed to putting a play a
process in place that will provide a
single view of debt to assist officers
when they decide what the best course
action is to recover debt ow to the
authorities
we accept it's not possible to implement
an integrated system across all areas of
work immediately
therefore working with the communities
team we've agreed to co-develop a system
for those who contact both us and
council officers to request a food
parcel first
we need to better understand what the
driving forces are behind the huge
increase in request food parcels and how
these might be reduced through other
interventions and support
we know that we have what has been
called the perfect storm approaching
demand for our services is set to
continue increasing
clients will have even more complex
issues and we are still managing with
the impact of covid
as above
we are
increasing advisor numbers
but that takes time
we have increased specialist stepped
advice capacity and we are looking at
improving our reach across the districts
with digital hubs and outreach
we are working smarter with improved and
increased phone advice and intend to
expand both lcas over time
whilst our business plans include
strategies to continue to diversify
through project funding we remain
dependent on the core funds from our
local authorities to to survive and are
of course continually grateful for those
too
the services we deliver across the
district support the vision and mission
for communities well-being housing
economy and environment
as per the report supplied to the
committee by the corporate management
communities
three-year rolling funding agreements
are in place through the revenue grant
for both organizations
speaking on behalf of mid-suffolk we are
pleased to report that we have been able
to build networks within the council
that have helped to improve
communication between us
there is more for us to do but the
commitment to work in partnership to
address any issues is very much
appreciated
the development of integrated systems
will be key to how we move forward and
we look forward to working with you
to deliver a better service to those in
need within our community
that concludes our presentation chair
thank you very much to both of you
um that was excellent um i think well i
certainly have learned a lot
and it's good to have an up-to-date
certainly a review of the last
uh the last year or so
to see what the added pressures have
been
so i'm going to open to the
committee for questions
uh councilor muller first and then
councillor scarf
yeah um simon
is there a particular reason why there
was such a sharp spike in october 21 for
the food bank referrals please
uh from a mid-suffolk perspective the
the the
spike has continued
um
we're unsure one of the things that
we're committed to do is work with the
community community teams in the new
year to try and bring in an integrated
system for food parcels in stone market
in particular
if i tell you that last week
we received 27 calls for help with the
food parcel
which is far greater than we would have
anticipated
and
even had a family of six turn up at the
door
that required immediate financial aid
because they had four fish cakes to feed
themselves until this week
so
it's unclear as to why that is but we do
need to bring in a more integrated
system so that we can try and break the
cycle
because there is a need
and we need to address that need thanks
simon thank you thank you
thank you chair um
well a number of questions really um
perhaps directed to simon um from the
mid-soccer point of view but it might be
relevant to colleen as well um
you talked about the food parcel
referrals to citizens advice and the way
that citizens advice try and offer a
holistic service so that if they come to
you for a food parcel there's usually
another
issue that they have as residents um
if they get referred to a food bank by
another referral agency
for example health or at churchill or
whatever um
what happens then do do those referral
organizations then
uh encourage them to contact citizen's
advice
so they can be done so we would hope so
but we can't
be sure that that would happen and i
also couldn't neither of us could
confirm if other referral agencies
carried out any sort of research or
investigation into the root cause
as a matter of um usual practice we see
some clients when they're going through
a difficult period quite regularly for a
food bank bank voucher but um i believe
there's a similar situation in in would
suffer to sudbury we believe it's
irresponsible to continue to give those
food bank vouchers and without giving
the client an appointment for a
completely holistic review of their
whole situation
because there's often a root cause it
can be an employment issue it can be
lack of incitement to benefits that
people have should be claiming
we've even found some financial abuse
by carrying out those type of
mandatory interviews when people want a
third or for the food voucher
so in mid-suffolk we have a situation
where we are not decision makers for the
food parcel referral we make the
referral
and part the primary food bank for us in
use is the stone market food bank
we are aware that there are a large
number of people other organizations
that refer to the food bank
we do not have the food bank's data on
who they might be
working with the customer operations
team
the
mid-south miss suffolk
element
element
also receive
calls as does those in baby
for
refer to make a referral for a food
parcel for them
we've now got an agreement some joint
working practice where
that person's details with their consent
are passed to us so that we can follow
them up
for another holistic provision
we are extremely keen in the new year to
look at the food bank
or food bank provisions
to bring in an integrated one system
so that we can all look at what is going
on and try and tackle it
thank you i mean i i think that's the
key to it integrated system um because
uh otherwise people are
becoming dependent on food parcels when
they're actual underlying reasons for
their need to become dependent on food
parcels is not being addressed so i
think i would very much welcome that
integrated system of working
i have another question it's something
that you've not referred to
either of you in your report as a county
councillor also a twin hatted member i'm
aware of the household support fund that
was allocated to suffolk county council
a figure i believe over five million
pounds um
i believe i'm correct in saying that
both councils midsubmit and baby
received an allocation from that which i
understood was about a quarter million
perhaps you can confirm that can i ask
you i mean what is the process or the
system uh involved in actually
allocating these funds is it has the
system been developed yet uh by the
councils and ca working in partnership
so um
the household support fund was 500
million across the country and we
understand that the suffolk element was
5.2 million
um
colleen alluded to it earlier that we um
traditionally we do not have not been a
charitable giving organization so we
have not provided direct financial
support but during the covid period last
year
emergency funding was made available and
we decided as a networking suffolk that
we would support that to took money from
the county council via suffolk community
foundation to provide financial aid to
individuals and families
what's happened on this household
support fund is that across suffolk 250
000 pounds has been provided for
charitable organizations to provide
direct charitable aid
and
sudbury and mid-suffolk are part of that
process
one of the things that we can't provide
aid on is rent or housing costs
it is our understanding that the
district council and its borough council
received 250 000 pounds from the county
council
to provide support to
people who were presenting with
issues in housing particularly rent
arrears
i believe at the moment there is uh from
this two district council's perspectives
here from the house team there is a
statement on the website
regarding how people can claim that
additional support
i think that the process is still being
worked up
i'm aware that customer operations team
are going to be part of that process so
as we will make the assumption that the
customer race team will probably take
those initial calls there will be some
form of application
and i would like to think that that we
moved on quite quickly because we do
have
a significant number of people in crisis
now
the other underlying fact that every
single bit of funding that we receive
currently
um from central government five whatever
route it gets to us
always comes with time scale and this
particular one is that all funding has
to be spent by the 31st of march 2022
which brings its own
issues
golf and then councillor barrett it's
really a supplementary question um
a chair and i i wonder perhaps
we've got the portfolio holder from mid
suffolk um here obviously because of the
time scale i'm a little concerned that
we might not actually spend that money
that we've received to help people in
desperate need
what what are we what steps are we
taking because it sounds like the
process isn't in place at the moment and
march is not a very long deadline away
what steps are we taking uh
as you're the mid-summit portfolio
holder
in order to ensure that we actually
allocate that funding to those most in
need
miss me it's me
thank you councillor scarf um i myself
don't have anything to do with customer
service um and calls so i will have to
take that back to the leader who is
portfolio portfolio holder for customer
service and find out exactly what we
have there and if um if royston knows
any more than i do
um please step in
i think you'll find uh councillor that
the actual money's been allocated to the
housing so it'll be the housing cabinet
so it's housing that have been given the
uh
the funding
hope that says
no i'm very sorry i deal with the
internal funding schemes for the for the
district council so no i'm not involved
in that scheme but
as we said if there is a i can look into
it and see what i can report back to
this to this body if you want me to
certainly thank you oh yeah thank you i
think this is probably something we're
going to have to bring up when we're
when we're looking at um
resolutions thank you
um council bow
thank you um just two quick questions
and then i'll go into a longer sort of
question um
you're based in sudbury which is on the
essex border do you you must have
clients from essex do you access funds
from essex no we don't
we get nothing from any other local
authority
in sudbury and district lca
we do see clients from essex from
colchester houston
and in particular because the colchester
lca has now taken a real downturn and
have
found themselves in a dreadful situation
with regards to losing local authority
funding and practically closed down from
what i can make out there um but there
is a bit of a two-way street that goes
on with cross-border
clients because we might see some from
essex
ipswich may see some of ours we may see
some from there as you know it does it
does it swings and roundabouts really so
we don't turn people away because they
come outside of our district but it does
it does all work out in the mix we may
have somebody that works in sudbury
sudbury but lives in mid suffolk so they
may come to us to see us when they're um
during their lunch break or something
and vice versa okay but no we don't we
don't get any um we don't get any
funding from anybody else yeah we're
very keen not to post code so
some some other offices um
not in our locality will post code so
they will only see people that are
within their own postcode area um but as
colleen says that when we look at our
data
um
by not postcoding is an even share
we do have so if we say in mid-subject
we may see people with mips which we
actually see just as many people from
mid-suffolk the same will apply
braintree
colchester as long as essex provides
some services to suffolk um residents i
guess then that that evens exactly yeah
exactly
um
the on the slides you showed us
um about primarily about universal
credit um
beneficiaries um
was that is that stats
your clients who are on universal credit
yeah
solely it doesn't reflect other clients
so did you take the stats from suffolk
those stats are from the dwp right i
wasn't quite sorry i quite
simon's um colleague got the um
statistics together right yeah let's do
wp stats yeah
and and well so i wanted to to just ask
you about um the food bank referrals um
councillor scarf just mentioned
something about
creating dependency and i'm concerned
about that as we as we go forward and
the growing nature of the
um
availability of food banks and and uh
as you've said in part of your
presentation you've talked about um not
providing the
solution the decision to clients but
allowing them to make their own
decisions which is you know
part part of
part of your your um your your sort of
um statement
um
i think the same applies to food banks
rather than just here's here's some food
for this week but you know they'll be
back next week and that that doesn't
change
and it's hard to see how that is going
to change if that is just
what's provided
is is there any
um
attempt to
uh educate to provide
um decision you know uh menu i do give
budgeting advice
sometimes known as financial
capabilities so pretty much every client
we see
obviously when it's completely
inappropriate it doesn't happen but as a
norm clients are offered benefit checks
and budgeting advice where need be
in particular when they are seeing us
with regards to debt issues so we will
have somebody who goes through all of
the incoming outgoings and talks about
where there might be savings made
um
at the moment i'm i'm just starting an
outreach in the phoenix center in
great cornard
waiting for the play and stay groups to
come back so that we can um we can make
more use of that
so we see then very young families
usually that are perhaps struggling with
with their incomes
and in particular my aim there is to get
a service for
financial capability to that client
group
but take it out there where they are you
know six sessions where there's a group
and run some on some training sessions
but i'm sure simon
we share your concerns yeah
it's the best way of describing it we're
dealing with multiple different food
banks
who have multiple different rules
so for in
the top north west part of mid-suffolk
we will be dealing with waverly waveness
a trussell trust
organisation and it's three three food
parcels
that's what people allowed in one year
three food
in
parcels
market we're not the decision maker
church run food bank
in washington willows there's a parish
council one we're not decision maker
we need one integrated system where we
can look at what is actually happening
and what is that need and how do we
address that need and some of that need
could well be
as hard as it is to say perhaps there's
still a need for food banks
you know because that yeah the the the
example i gave where the family of six
turned up at our door with four fish
cakes
right
you know with the best one in the world
go and say let's sit down do your budget
and that's not what they need there and
then but
how did they get to the position where
they've got four fish cakes
you know and and that's the sort of
thing that we want this one integrated
system to start looking at
but we do share your concerns
and
we hope that people
will work with us all the other
organizations will work with us to
develop this one system i think we do
have to remember that particularly in
current times regardless of
any delving into what's causing the
situation or
financial capability training that
people are in just such dreadful
dreadful situations for no no
cause of their own and it's it's a
impact of all of the things we talked
about a perfect storm
drops in new universal credit increased
energy costs and treat increased petrol
costs if they're having to commute to
work increases in everything
that you can think of lately isn't there
and and
income going down
people are losing losing jobs and maybe
having to go into lesser paid jobs but a
lot of the people that we see who need
food bank vouchers are people who are
working
their families of
households in work
unfortunately it can create more inequal
health inequalities i think if they're
relying on tinned foods and dry dry
goods there's all sorts of implications
council field
of council field next and then council
casting
thank you um a couple of points
one um you said you didn't understand
the spike in sort of october in need i
just wondered how that stacked up with
the end of the furlough scheme which i
that's possibly the cause of it
if you take lots of money away from
people were they likely to finish up in
trouble i guess um but the the real
issue was about you talking about an
integrated system for a few banks and
things i'm fairly well aware that i
think it's fine to operate out of
my ward really
i think a reasonably large operation um
have considerable concern about working
too closely in combination with some of
the other banks
you know really on sort of ethical
grounds or whatever that some of these
forgive me if i should have said the
possibility is something like a church
based organization will will prefer
people from from christian church and if
you happen to be from some other faith
perhaps you don't get such a sympathetic
treatment so i wonder how you're gonna
tackle that issue because it's that and
also the data protection issues of um
passing information from organisation to
organisation is something that which you
do have to be careful
so in mid-southwark
stone market food bank is one stone
market food bank is a church
organization
it doesn't
define who it supports through religion
in fact quite the opposite is our
experience of that particular food bank
there are a lot of food banks
around
and as i said earlier lots have
different ideas as to what support is
required
regarding data protection we have data
sharing agreements with food banks
so we are able to share
those data we will share it by the legal
basis of consent
because quite clearly if someone's come
to us to ask for a food parcel we need
to share that
otherwise they're not going to get the
food parcel
it
i mean some of the spike in october is
going to be the removal of the 20 pound
uplift on universal credit
somewhat replaced by those who were in
work on universal credit in december
where the taper of the amount you can
earn
replaced that 20 pounds but did nothing
for those that aren't
earning and on the chart we showed you
earlier which showed that the those who
are unable to work because they are too
sick is showing a steady increase
those people would have lost a 20 a 20
pound uplift because they're not in work
and cannot take advantage of the taper
um
we
we the integrated system you know like
it or not i would really like everything
to be integrated tomorrow
but i have to accept
that we're not in that position so we're
going to look at the food banks in the
first instance
to see because the food banks a lot of
things draw from the food bank so
there's so much holistic support that we
can give from the food bank so in stone
market for instance
we're in receipt some energy funding
so everybody that makes a food parcel
request to us is referred for energy
advice
and as part of that the conversation
starts on energy advice and then lots of
other
different issues will come out from that
um
but
you know i i really have got a lot of
hope
that when we report to you next year
that we'll be able to report a far more
positive
system
for food banks within the district
councillor casten and then councilman
mclaren
thank you very much um
i just wanted to ask about the kind of
structure of this network how closely
the bureaus work with each other because
what we've got is lots of different
levels of funding
in uh different
bureaus um
do we um
how much um
pooling or if any of resources funding
and services goes on in between bureaus
and um
is it ever the case that
a um
especially with telephone advice
that one bureau will refer to another
bureau because they've got
more specialization or
more resource to deal with the inquiry
okay so
um we're we're independent
local citizens advice and we do work
differently in some respects and as
you've pointed out we have different
levels of income
we also have um varied projects
i might have something at sudbury that
simon doesn't have and vice versa
we do work very closely together we work
closely together in
looking at anything that we can
do jointly with regards to diversifying
and project work
and also with regards to
sharing of skills sharing of supporting
each other for example i've had a
situation recently where i was very
short of what we call session
supervisors and simon was able to allow
some of the hours that he's worked for
him
to come over to sudbury and work for me
um other than that we we not really
sharing there wouldn't be much need to
refer clients
because
the clients would get the same service
from each lca
but i can't think of anything to add to
that really simon can you
so we currently have seven citizen
advices across suffolk
uh all independent charities and
independent trustee boards
you'll be aware that east suffolk
council
did a piece of work with the three
census devices in east suffolk and our
understanding is that they have they
will be proceeding to merge
which makes very good sense bearing in
mind that that is now one council
we as colleen says we we will share
resources as is appropriate so we have
provided some supervision support to
colleen all right to ensure that that
continued we have both undertaken
to send trainee generalist advisers on a
course provided by suffolk west citizens
advice
because they had a better training
provision at that particular
time
we meet up as citizens of isis across
suffolk to discuss opportunities
um
two sister organizations are still
providing the suffolk advice and support
service telephone
advice service
as we are one network we work through a
sister crm system called casebook and
what that allows is that if we are if
somebody in another office takes a call
and that office isn't the most
appropriate person to answer that call
then that we will be tasked through that
case book system and a prime example of
that would be
that i would not necessarily know what
charitable support
sudbury district could provide for
somebody in that district in baby
district and vice versa colleen would
not know what was available in mid
suffolk so if so and charitable support
is something that we're being asked for
all the time
and so that's something that we would
task back and a local office then would
deal with
our what we do is although it does look
that we're quite fragmented
we don't work fragmented
you know we don't work fragmented
and
we will do everything we can won't we
going forward to for every opportunity
so
in the new year you know
colleen's going to come on with the
virtual advice we're really really keen
to try and get virtual advice
across both districts so that there is
not a hub as such because that implies a
building
but a device you know we want to work
with the parish councils can you hold
the device can you help the person get
on to that device and have a virtual
conference with somebody that needs it
does it need to be citizen could it be
healthcare could it be the housing team
that's what we want to and that will be
a joint bid to the lottery
to try and fund that
so
we're doing all we can
we're fully aware that particularly at
county level that that view is not
always thought that we are doing all we
can but locally i can assure you we are
i would just also add that i think that
during this particular two-year period
the benefit of us being in our locality
has been
why we have succeeded in what we've
delivered yeah it's it's local because
it's been local and we've understood the
local need
and that's not always the case across
larger organizations
sorry could i just um
i'm still on um
how regularly does that occur where um
say mid suffolk would send resources to
um sudbury um is that a regular thing or
is is that
a rare occasion
it's an occasion just when there was
need it was because of a particular
situation where i had several people
leave
at the same time one of the fallouts
from the pandemic where people decided
that they wanted to give up jobs
so i had several people in the same role
leaving at the same time so it puts in a
bit of a spot and and that's when we
were able to go and and get some of that
that sort of supervision help from
another lca
and simon had the capacity uh in in
addition to that i've also i also um
[Music]
outsource my need for debt supervision
to
ipswich lca so i i share one of their
special specialist
supervisors
and some of the hours that he works are
for sudbury so we do a lot of sharing
it's as need be we're always there we
call out to each other when we need it's
more in a situation where
something comes up and we and we we need
to a bit of help bit of support from
another lca for instance so colleen's
been successful recently in receiving in
been getting a lottery bid
you know we we're in mid-suffolk we've
not ever been successful in getting a
lottery
funding you know we'll work
with uh colleen as a particular
individual that has that responsibility
i have an individual that has a similar
responsibility they'll work together
they'll develop the bid together
um so it's about sharing that knowledge
and that experience
and
although it might not see me all the
time we are actually getting a bit
better at it
it doesn't always look like it i do
appreciate that but we are getting
better at it and the beauty of us having
that network was when colleen had this
situation which
was instant
we had the capacity and the capability
to be able to support
a neighbouring
office that meant that the residents
didn't see any impact at all
had those supervisors been
shared around
as a you know a hull
then they'd have gone on but the impact
of losing those would have been great
um it might be worth mentioning the um
the touch does it touch down or touch
stones
report the east
touchdown
my my ball trustee board spent a lot of
time looking at that researching it and
making comparisons
um to find that for the east coast three
lca it made perfect sense for a merger
but for sudbury there were there were no
games there were only losses
but there was an extensive piece of work
carried out to establish that
information
using what was a very useful report well
i can assure you both trustee boards um
they do talk to each other the chairs
talk to each other and we are doing
an awful lot more
strategic planning
as trustee boards now to see where we're
going to be where we want to be
in the future and that can only come
from greater collaboration
thank you um councilman mclaren thank
you
sorry
um i was very interested in your comment
about the telephone services
increasing in the contacts
and the reduction in the email contacts
so
do we assume from that that that
that the people that normally emailed
i'd refer to
a telephone system the the increase to
telephones has been the obvious reason
is that that's the main
route that people have to get through to
us with face-to-face
drop-in and appointment sessions closing
down
um
it's more the loss of face-to-face
services that's increased the need for
telephone advice
and the point about telephone advice is
that we've been there are some positives
strangely i think as we've all realized
that have come out of this whole
situation and for us it's definitely
been our improved use of technology
and our improved use of telephone advice
and updating up skilling people whereas
if it got a little bit complicated an
advisor would say oh come in and see
somebody they've had to deal with it on
the phone we've got a lot better at it
and so we've we've realized that for a
lot of clients they prefer that they'd
rather that than come and sit in the
waiting room be it an appointment or a
drop-in session
and this is where we've picked up
younger age groups too because that's
their preference usually
particularly people who are perhaps of
working age while working during a
coffee break or a lunch break can give
us a call rather than come and visit us
but um
we we are finding that the um preference
for telephone advice has increased
on the part of clients part
emails i don't think there's been such a
dramatic
have you had a big drop in emails we
never had a massive
demand by email anyway
so i don't know that that's changed
too much
emails emails at mid suffolk have
certainly increased we have a contact
form on our website that allows all the
appropriate data protection questions to
be asked yeah we do that so so
but this is this is the thing that each
office
caters to its locality
so in mid-suffolk we definitely saw a
big change in demographic it was much
younger much more digitally literate
um and
our usual client base
at that time because they've been given
additional money through uc and they
weren't being chased for other things
that client base was not
coming to the form
i can assure you
it's returning
and we do have a lot of people turn up
at our door though we're not doing them
droppings but the things with phone the
the phones is a far more efficient way
of us
dealing with clients and then when we
identify someone who is particularly
vulnerable or who has
a very complex case work then they'll
they will come in for appointments there
will always be a need for face-to-face
advice and and sadly
the the real losers in the whole
situation with regards to our client
groups of those who haven't been able to
access help from us at all
because they haven't been able to
actually come in and see somebody
so we're we're pleased that we've got
that back in place now i was going to
make a comment because it actually
reflects when people are in need
they
actually like to speak to somebody
rather i think it's a lesson for
councils as well
that people in need are really not going
to go online
they want to speak with somebody so i
think that's very commendable
that the telephone service was being
used can i ask about the debt advisor
colleen
is that the only one you've got at the
moment we we have a part-time two days
per week debt advisor
and in addition we now have somebody
full-time who we've spent the past year
training
to become a debt advisor so because
it's a very skilled job actually it's
very specialist i worked with the ihack
as a volunteer okay
so you've got i didn't achieve i didn't
achieve the advisor level but but it is
very complex and very skilled and i'm
pleased that you've managed to appoint
that but presumably that person will be
spread around a bit
the the full-time person yeah um
and they will be
having a sort of split of telephone
advice
and the training that the person has
undertaken has been to really get them
on up skilled on telephone advice
and also face to face where need be so
similar to our general advice services
saving the face-to-face for those
clients that really need it
and the reasoning behind it is that we
know that the demand for debt advice is
is just going to rock it
as things will open they are opening up
and we are seeing the steady increase
already
and so that we we're in the best
position we can to meet demand with what
we did have one for
one part-time person and now a full-time
in fact nationally
the funding part that i referred to in
my presentation that we both took
advantage of
it was a national plan to train
i think it was something like
two 100 people with citizens advice
um throughout the country
so that
this time now a year on there were 100
there were an army of debt advisors all
already and waiting to manage the um the
estimated wave of debt demand that we're
going to see
so thank you
i've just got one last question
as a ward member for
that works on the shortly peninsula
um
i i really need to ask the question
about citizens advice easter i i welcome
the fact that hadley are going to
recommence yeah but that leaves an awful
lot of people
without any service at all so do you
think that the majority of say my
residents will go into ipswich
what i'm hoping is that we're going to
cover that need better with the new
digital project that we've been talking
about today
it's always been the hope to
cover the area better
from sudbury and we would just we were
just getting there when it all hit we i
don't know if you remember any of you
but we were in gp surgeries with
outreach projects and those were we were
into social prescribing we were really
you know getting a foothold there and of
course when the surgery is closed down
that whole project just went with it
really there was no future for it once
it was clear that it was going on for as
long as it was
so we're looking at getting back in that
situation and of course holbrook and
shotley were on the
on the list of surgeries we were moving
into
um but at the moment we are looking at
the digital access to provide more than
telephone and email advice
i'm sure we'd welcome that yeah no we
we're looking at it we were we were
nearly there okay and it all went wrong
yeah thank you thank you chair
that's the scarf
thank you um
there's just one question i think i have
but it's not for the officers from ca
it's for potentially mr emerson over
there over there just to give you notice
that i've got one questioning before we
lose the chance to do that
okay um
anybody else counsel about and counsel
the field with questions for the two
officers thank you yeah
um i think it's just very clear that you
provided a
really good service to residents um
in the last sort of very difficult
period and adapted well to what's going
on
um i just wondered if you could tell us
approximate waiting times that people
generally
when they when they first contact you
how long do they have to wait i'll speak
to sudbury and then i'm sure simon can
answer the same question because again
there'll be similarities but differences
um for us currently we are answering
people are leaving a message on the
telephone and they're being called back
in the same day
and similarly with emails they're being
responded to in the same day if it's
discovered that they need an appointment
they will be seen that week usually
because they say the appointments are
being um really sort of discretion's
being used as to who needs them most so
we're getting people that really need
them in service appointments
if we really are overwhelmed which i
have to say over the last couple of
weeks it has felt a bit overwhelming
then there may be one or two people that
are leaving messages on the phone asked
to ring advice line
which is the national
helpline but generally it is an advisor
from our
lca that gets back to them
we have our own local telephone number
in sudbury which is quite unique and
we're determined to keep that and
it just makes it easier for
us to know that we're there for the baba
residents
so in mid-suffolk
our model is slightly different in that
we don't
have a facility for people to leave a
message
we answer the phone as it comes in
our average um call the first call
answering is 83
and we know from our data that a lot of
people that call us back are we do
answer that day
um
as colleen said we try and now do
everything through the first contact
which is the telephone if that can't be
done in our particular case debt uh
first call from debt will be within the
week at the present time although that
may increase when we start seeing larger
numbers welfare benefits generally that
again will be within the week or the
week after but we have to provide
prioritize those who have got mandatory
reconsiderations that require a quicker
response to that um would
colleen as in that uni because we've got
two local telephone numbers as well so
we we don't um partake in the national
advice line
we are we answer our own calls
so generally speaking it is not that
long email response is the same day
also we mentioned earlier in our
presentation about the suffolk
information partnership which is a warm
handover scheme that's another email
system that comes in to us so we receive
an awful lot of referrals like that
they'll be dealt with
primarily that day
um
as colleen says though i mean november
for us was much much busier than october
and december doesn't look like we've
been less busier than november so
um
but hopefully you know what but if if
as members here if you find that we are
not you know delivering what we need to
do because people aren't getting through
to us then please contact us you know
and we'll investigate and see what might
be going wrong or what the reason might
be
you know why that would be but um
hopefully
we're delivering what we need to deliver
at this time yeah we're meeting now
command
just a little point then it might be
worth making if we do have to ask people
to wait for a week or so to see a
specialist for example a debt advisor
our general advisors and i'm sure it's
the same in simon's lca2 we'll look at
all the emergencies and priorities
whilst they're waiting for that
appointment so people aren't just sort
of put off their that we check what can
we do right now before we get stuck into
the real job
thank you were there any other cancer
field yes thank you
thank you just a bit perhaps about your
virtual service
i was wondering when that's likely to be
delivered it does sound a bit of a way
away
a sort of background for that question i
guess is that um
it must be pretty hard dealing with
complex debt issues
you know if you don't if the client
doesn't want to run up a fortune on
their mobile phone or um
you know i've been dealing with uh
people bullied by an estate management
company recently and
one that was even with some of that
relatively simple the number of sort of
line items that
you you've got to understand and grasp
what the relationships are is far from
trivial so really
you know virtual service
sounds very useful
but when
so
if we are running it in two locations um
in mid-suffolk and we were fortunate
during the lockdown that we received
funding to uh look at virtual advice in
rural locations
um from the business energy part of the
department government um and that's
allowed us to develop some um
some strategies
because we did some things that didn't
work and we did some things that did
work so what we've been now doing share
our experiences with the
customer operations team at district
council who
have
fully bought into the idea
that virtual is another means it's not
the only means but it's another means of
contacting
all of us
so
unfortunately as we've gone through the
pandemic as we've about to do something
something else has changed that's then
brought in greater restrictions
so we are committed to trying to get as
many virtual devices in every single
parish that we can
with somebody that is willing to be
responsible for it
and then can help the person get on to a
virtual call with us because the sort of
devices that we've we've deployed allow
documents to be scanned
um you know at the meeting so the
document is scanned and is emailed
straight through to the advisor
um
we'd really really like to develop a a
joint booking system
so that you know it's not just citizens
advice and district councils but other
statutory authorities and other
charitable organizations can utilize
that
but virtual advice is just one means of
doing it
the problem with outreaches is that
physical outreaches are very expensive
to deliver
and very resource heavy
but
as we are found in mid-south look most
definitely needed in i
so you know we keep an eye on it all the
i didn't mean to be a pun there but we
do keep an eye on what's going on across
all the other data across the district
and where we pick up where we've got
pockets of need
that might not be appropriate for
virtual it might be appropriate for
something that needs to be in person
so again i'm hopeful
that we will be able to report to you
something very positive
at the meeting next year but i'm hoping
that you will hear lots of things before
then of what we're doing
thank you i was about to say next month
or next year but you seem to implying
next year
i would like next month
i accept that it might take slightly
longer to bring all the parties together
thank you
i've got a couple of questions i think
they're linked
i think one of you said
that well it showed on the screen that
the number of people claiming universal
credit number of people who were
claiming universal credit came along to
you
went up shot up in may 2020 and i think
one of you said that
you're expecting there to be another
step up in the near future in the the
number of people coming for
advice you're on universal credit
so that that leads me to a question
about when people come in to debt
do they find they quickly get into a
position where they're owing money to
a lot of different people for instance
they're maxed out on their credit card
and then they realize that that or the
net their next step then is perhaps
to uh not pay their rent or to not pay
their council tax
um so
is
what i'm concerned about is these there
may be people out there
who when they get into a really
difficult situation they come to you and
by that time
they're they're owing money in three
three or four different places
um and they might be being pursued by
one authority for one debt another
authority for another debt or two
different parts of the same authority
um
how do how do you deal with that
are you able to deal with that is there
anything that
we can do by by raising a concern that
that is happening so that perhaps
there can be a better system
so um
it is fair to say that when people come
to us for debt advice
it's not normally somebody who's just
missed one payment
and it's not somebody who just has one
payment missed on one thing
so when they come into our debt service
the experian report is done so that we
understand fully what debt is owed and
we work out what is priority debt that
needs to be dealt with there and then we
also have another tool in the toolbox
which is breathing space which allows us
to place somebody on 60 days
wait before any other further
enforcement action can happen um
at both offices we use that when that is
useful where call law enforcement is at
the door primarily
because it can be used
by some clients as a delaying tactic
when actually the end of it's the same
result but so we have a number of tools
at our disposal
we look at the priority debt we deal
with the priority debt
where we can we find financial
charitable financial aid that might
assist people to clear some of that debt
and that's been very
the household support fund and the
earlier covid fund were very useful for
that in allowing us to do that that just
gives us a little bit more
maneuverability without dealing with the
person's debt management issues
um
but i mentioned in my in the
presentation about this single view of
debt
for the authority
so we do have a situation where
um council tax and housing benefit is
administered by
suffolk revenues partnership
on behalf of both district councils
and therefore they they have a view of
those debts
but the rent officers within the housing
team do not have a view of the council
tax debt and vice versa srp do not have
a view of the council rent debt
so we we have had
situations where
somebody has been pursued for council
tax debt
liability order issued at court
approached by law and court enforcement
agents
entered into a payment plan
and then the next day contacted by
council rent
and put on a payment plan for owed
council rent or
attachments to universal credits
and what we would really really like is
one single view of debt
so that the council officers can see
what that person owes the authority
and to work together
to deal with that as one debt rather
than several different debts
there is work has been done on it and
i'm given to understand that the work is
going to continue this commitment to do
so so i'm hopeful again chair that we'll
be able to report to you
that you know
before the next meeting that we have
you call us back that we have made some
considerable progress in that
and um
we can help people who are in crisis a
little bit better uh through debt owed
to the authority
yeah
yes thank you for that but it seems that
this is something needs to move a pace
doesn't it because if we've got if we've
got this increased number of people
coming onto universal credit that could
well lead to more people entering into
this sort of
problem
so
i i are you
are you concerned that it may not move
quickly enough or are you content that
it will be in place
when you get this added extra
number of number of people coming to you
what we have done is there's what we can
do at the moment you know we've raised
it as a concern with the district
councils and the officers and work has
been done
to try and align the two
bits of data um it's obviously not gonna
be a particularly simple task there are
issues there are gonna be data
protections there's gonna be lots of
issues but i'm told that the council
officers are working on it
as we speak
and i would like to think that we will
have a resolution
within the first couple of months of
next year
um i've got nothing to suggest chair
that that would not be happening
um
but the fact that it's being discussed
here now
minuted
is uh you know
that will be helpful
and we have we have a cabinet member
albeit not for that that particular area
but we have a cabinet member in the room
who i'm sure could take this back to
cabinet and i would encourage police if
you would do that
um and it's not a communities or grants
issue but
royston perhaps you can take it on to
colleagues
in in the relevant departments
um i have got one other question and is
for our cabinet member
and
um
you may recall uh council flatman that
we met on the 15th of february 2021
this joint overview scrutiny committee
and
one of the resolutions was as follows
that the joint overview and scrutiny
committee confirmed the previous
resolution made at the last review that
the three-year rolling
funding arrangements review be subject
to indexation
on an annual review basis finances
permitting as a measure of importance we
attach to ongoing lca funding
do you know whether
it has been discussed or it has been
agreed that there will be indexation
of the
grant funding
thank you chair
it was not adopted
however
ca mid suffolk has received additional
funding this year from us we redirected
the funding that would normally be
awarded to thetford and district for the
support they provided in eye
and surrounding areas this is because
thetverden district did not apply for
funding so we redirected that funding to
mid suffolk cab for them to extend the
reaching to i
so
they have had some funding but we have
not linked it to index
and that went before cabinet
thank you
um well i i i think we might be debating
that point that's uh doing during the
next uh little while
um
if there are no other questions from
members
um
can we move on to debate
um
i don't know how long we're gonna take
the debate we're going to take a break
um when we've got some draft
recommendations so if we can
have our debate and come up with draft
recommendations the officers have said
that they they would then
fine-tune these into uh
into recommendations
uh whilst we go and have a cup of coffee
or whatever so we'll have a break of
about 10 minutes then
so can i ask uh
who would like to start the debate
counselor scarf
oh sorry um
okay oh sorry you did i'm yeah i'm very
sorry yes
thank you chair yeah um
it's in specific on page eight of the
document
mitsubishi
and their three-year rolling program um
reveals obviously that this year they
received 95 500 which included the
distant fedford uplift which was one of
the recommendations that we made at our
last
ca review
looking to the future years of 22 23 and
23 24
it gives us a baseline of 86 700 in
brackets with potential addition of 8
800 pounds obviously that was the dis
and thetford element
at the end of the table
it says the above table reflects the
three-year agreements in place with
outcomes of midsuffoc with thetford and
dis
i think that should be ca during
december this year
ca midsuffer may be awarded with an
additional eight thousand eight hundred
and ten pounds for their extended work i
wonder as the grants officer the only
person actually we can ask the question
of uh today uh could you confirm
whether discussions with dis and
thetford uh have taken part have been
concluded or whatever so we've got some
certainty as to the 8
800 plate
uh thank you council scarf um
we haven't had any more communication
with this and
ca we have we i had some communication
with them earlier this year to see
whether they were
looking to re-establish the service that
would cover
i and the surrounding areas outside of
dis that have
had clients that have accessed them in
the past
we haven't heard anything more from this
and that on that matter we've i met with
simon a few weeks ago who
said that this we're not coming forward
we're not going to be offering a service
in suffolk so on the basis of that
discussion yes so we'll be offering the
8 000 that we had been offering to this
in favor and moving it to
mid-suffolk ca for the foreseeable
i think that clarifies the issue chair
it
now quite obvious that they will mid
suffolk ca will get the distance
thetford or the original dis and fatford
element um for the outreach service that
they've done and as mr clifton has said
they are already offering that service i
was just concerned about the continuity
of the funding for that provision
so thank you thank you and and i think
as the flatman you also referred to that
8110
and you believe that that will be
put into the amount to mid suffolk
i believe so but we can clarify that
when we know more
thank you
sorry so yeah um are we now into debate
with no more questions
so who would like to to start the debate
council field
yes i wouldn't say really i've heard a
lot that uh
reinforces the view that uh the cab
provides a very valuable service and
that
the sort of integrated approach to
people's issues
seems
of substantial value
can't be more emphasized than the point
that's been made about uh
the uh
slp can't um
with council tax debt can't see rent
debt within our own organization
it seems
perfectly obvious that that's something
that needs to be addressed and addressed
pretty rapidly
obviously we have to control um bad
debts of our own but uh
ditching families in even deeper
problems than they're in when they when
they
at the beginning is not a good technique
i wouldn't have thought so
i sort of applaud the works being done i
think we really should have a
recommendation that says we should sort
that issue out as rapidly as is
reasonably possible
and by that i mean within days and weeks
not within years thank you
thank you council field did i see
another hand was it counselor
i'll counsel the counselor scarf and
then counselor barrett thank you
thank you chair well looking at our
scoping document that we had put before
us on page 11 we had to sort of satisfy
ourselves as a joint committee um
about the response from
two cas
on behalf of our two councils and i
think
from what we've heard this morning
we've got sufficient reassurance that
both cas are operating to the best of
their abilities during this very
difficult time in offering a variety of
ways for our residents to access their
services so i'm very satisfied about
that i think they've answered all the
areas of inquiry that we had listed
within the scoping document and the
scoping document actually was very
useful as a reminder to us
i think as councillor fielders
reiterated i think the um
the the joint way of working the single
uh view of debt seems to me to be one of
the biggest issues that has come out of
today's uh presentation from
the ca and
surely it it must be something that that
we introduce at the earliest possible
opportunity because it does make things
work easier
i'm very interested in
the responses we got about the way that
the food banks operate i think there is
another
big issue there potentially because i'm
concerned that people may drop through
the cracks they may access a food bank
and the food bank literally
provides that food parcel to them
that week without actually exploring the
possibility or to help the citizens of
advice or indeed both authorities can
give them in terms of uh debt management
so i think that that obviously is
another issue
um
i'm quite concerned actually
perhaps our wording of our motion when
we last reviewed ca perhaps wasn't
clarified enough
that the intention certainly from my
recollection of the meeting was
that the two district councils provided
an inflationary uplift and we didn't
specify whether that was cpi rpi
we we asked them to investigate a
reasonable uplift
a three-year rolling funding agreement
is all very well but if there is no
inflationary uplift
then
it might as well be a three-year funding
agreement with that without rolling
because it doesn't it doesn't allow for
any extra increase in costs and there
are clearly some considerable increase
in costs that ca
already uh having to accommodate and
potentially within the next few months
some very serious extra costs associated
so i would hope that the joint committee
would make in no uncertain terms a
recommendation to the two cabinets
of the two authorities that a
inflationary increase was considered as
part of the rolling program i would also
hope that the disinfectant element now
that's been cleared up is actually built
into
uh mid-suffolk cas and that might
obviously be a recommendation that
obviously only mid-southward members of
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee could actually consider
[Music]
i think
with the revenue grant funding there is
there is potentially an issue because i
accept that
as the two authorities only receive a
one-year funding arrangement from
central government there is no certainty
for those two authorities as to what
their arrangements financially will be
in future years
but i think in terms of the revenue
grant system
the overall
amount
that's awarded under those schemes by
both
councils we ought to consider that there
is an inflationary or consideration of
an inflationary increase in terms of the
other revenue grants
that that we make as authorities ca are
substantial revenue grants that we make
but surely other organizations are in
the same situation and i think it would
be helpful
if all revenue grant funding move to a
three-year rolling arrangement for for
all revenue grants that the councils
make and that might be something that we
would consider
so i think we've learned a lot this
morning
and i think it's been very valuable that
ca have come to us again and would
actually thoroughly recommend that we
actually have another look at ca next
year because i'd be very interested to
see whether some of the recommendations
that we potentially make today and some
of the uh implications of the way that
they operate their services with on
behalf of both our districts residents
are actually able to be implemented and
how quickly they'll be able to implement
it so i would certainly support us
reviewing ca and our arrangements with
ca next year
thank you caster scarf
caster barrett
thank you um
i
agree what's being said about the
single view of debt because it's
important to use the the fee this
feedback that we've been provided with
this is an area we can add value as a
committee
uh by recommending its immediate you
know uh implementation really
on the food bank um
we need we need some sort of tie-in um
needed to improve the education advice
not just on budgeting but also on the
skills needed to
assemble a healthy nutritious meal on a
on a budget
um i think there are some
we need some tie-in with the some of the
cookery lessons that have been provided
in the county
to get people signed up who are
accessing food banks they seem to be the
the the most the people most in need of
that that valuable service
so i'd like to see some some
recommendation about
that thank you
um who i got next councillor mclaren
thank you
thank you chair um
well i'm really
probably because i had some experience
with ihack
i'm very keen that
in weber we perhaps improve the level of
debt advice
and i am aware that we've got us
an amount of money here
that uh weber
contribute to
but the work that they've done in
sudbury this year has been amazing but
i'm still aware that
sort of my end of the district is
without that advice
and um
for me it begs the question whether we
should be looking at increasing the
funding for weber
and the debt advice especially i know
lots of people
has come as something new
but
that advice has been integral to all
these services for many years
and the pandemic has just accelerated
that
but i'm
i was pleased about the new appointment
but i think we should be increasing that
level of
debt advice uh because it's going to it
is with us it has been with us for years
and it is so skilled
and it takes a long time to train a debt
advisor so i'm
i'm sort of considering i'm sorry the
cabinet member for baber is not here
today because i would have liked to have
asked the question about
the um inflationary um
additions
but i i want to look for some increase
in the
the contribution from baby thank you
chair
thank you caster casting
yeah i think um for me
looking at
the different funding in different areas
and the fairness of that was the um
was the concern
with this but um obviously we
scrutining scrutinizing these two
bureaus and i think they um they do very
well um the um
the um
i've um
i quite often deal with
residents of brantford just enabling and
give sending them links to websites or
speaking to next-door neighbors and just
this is just such an incredibly um
important
service provided
the um
we're here to um
what was the
to receive sufficient assurance
and
i think what i found is that the cab are
extremely effective
extremely well managed
and um doing it
doing a really good job and
mid-suffocate definitely receiving value
for money for a large amount of um
the funding
that the cab are receiving from them um
i think mid-suffolk is working
for
the classes for um
to teach people to make the most of
what they've got um i'm i'm not sure if
um babies what babe is doing with that i
haven't been following but um councillor
flatman has been had several projects
and been working really hard to assist
with that so um
i think um
yeah for me i'm i'm very pleased with
what i've heard and
i think um
i think a lot's been delivered
thank you
counselor muller
yes i would like to endorse basically
what uh counselor castle and councillor
scarce said um i think it makes absolute
sense that um
we make sure that any rent payments and
council tax where there are arrears are
you know paid one rather than sort of in
two different ways that that makes total
sense to me
but i'd also like to thank
you know simon and colleen today for all
the incredibly hard work that you've
done during the actual pandemic and as a
trustee board member at mid-suffolk we
do get regular updates from simon
and i'd like to thank him personally for
all the hard work that he and his team
have done and i would appreciate if you
could pass those comments on on to your
team for that simon thank you thank you
thank you do i have any
anything else anything from anybody
can i just run through my notes this is
um in no particular order
and i've written down probably about six
or seven different
potential recommendations
that we thank the um
the lca chief officers and their
respective staff for their work
that we
have been given reassurance that both
cas are operating a very are operating
very effectively and efficiently and
they responded well to all our lines of
inquiry
that the councils take a single view of
debt in respect of housing rent
and council tax
debts and
some some words around some integration
um
a
recommendation around food banks
there's better integration more more
sharing information advice on nutrition
and
ask for food banks to refer clients to
to cas
the recommendation to cabinets in
respect of a three-year rolling
funding with inflation
we see confirmation from cabinet
which is a mid-suffolk one
uh com confirmation from uh miss other
cabinet that the
8810 thetford and disc funding is
allocated to mit suffolk ca
that cabinet consider a three-year
rolling programme of grants to other
uh receivers of
revenue grants
that we we review again
i've written down december 2022 but i'm
going to ask the the chief officers if
december is the best time because i can
imagine that coming here today was not
ideal wonder whether a different month
might be any better i'll come back to
that in a second
the last one i've written down is
that
in the um in baber
a recommendation to baby cabinet that
extra funding
that they provide extra funding to
enable the ca to make greater provision
of debt advice
so if i come back to the the question is
is
is now a good time to
it is
one nod i'm getting
yes it's fine okay
so we will
yeah yeah
um we
you last presented in february i just
wondered whether
a different month was better but um 12
months from now would be would be ideal
i think
okay so i've written all that lot down
council field
i wonder would it be appropriate to add
something about acceleration of virtual
links um
clearly um providing some form of hubs
in the community
are beneficial not only to the
cab but to other council services and
perhaps other providers and
i'm well aware that the county did
provide links in libraries god knows how
many years
10 to 15 years ago but that exercise
needs moving into the current day and
age i guess
so something to say that we could get ic
people or any other appropriate group to
accelerate the provision of facilities
to allow
video conferencing remote hubs into
particularly into the cab but into other
relevant bodies perhaps as well
so would you
include councils health and
cas in that yes
it's just an issue of how one does it i
mean libraries have uh
links some village halls which seem an
appropriate sort of location some also
have
acceptable internet connections
quite a few of the smaller ones do not
so there's sort of two levels of issue
we need to address one is what equipment
and things is appropriate and i think as
was mentioned who looks after it and who
provides training for
people who don't know how to access
stuff the other one is what locations
are necessary and
do we need to persuade someone like say
bt to provide free internet connections
to such locations but
if we just ask for the program to be
accelerated and for there to be some
focus that would probably cover all
those points thank you so this would be
a recommendation to cabinet that they
seek an acceleration to this program and
presumably the funding to do it funding
to do it and recognising the cost
reductions that it will bring
thank you
if there are no other suggestions for
recommendations uh
cancer barrett
i think when you talked about food bank
she said um advice budgeting advice but
that's got to be linked with
menu planning as well
my budget implies it's broadly
their whole
household income but
that must be linked with planning meal
planning as well and the referral to the
um cooking programs if where they're
running
and thank you for that i had written
down advice on nutrition and budgeting i
probably didn't have my teeth in the
right place with the words to come out
in the right order sorry about that so
are you happy then with
um
advice on nutrition and budgeting
and and
coordination of reference to
cas
and appropriate
um
just nutrition and
nutrition and cook and cooking do you
have both in there
sorry
free skills classes i think
are provided yeah from okay
between between us do we
i think we've probably got enough to
spend 10 minutes oh counselor mclaren
and i just asked the question well this
business about food banks
i mean it is a problem i think
nationally it's a problem we've got lots
of food banks doing lots of things
is this
a national do you think it's a national
that or it should be raised
because across the country
some are good and some are better
but they do work completely i mean i'm
very familiar with finding ipswich
works very different to the and i'm
familiar with trussell as well
the trussel trust
and it looks as if there should be a
national
coordination of food banks
um
yeah i can i can see where you're coming
from with that one
but i think if we can sort it out in
suffolk to start off with if we if we
are successful in finding ways of
integrating these things together but
who would who would actually do that
it's all right as recommending it but
who would who would actually do
that um simon yeah
um
the meeting that i had with royston and
with um
the corporate manager for communities
two weeks ago
one of the single one of the integrated
systems for a single
system
we we would talk we spoke about food
banks
so it would be my assumption that that
would be the communities team
that will be responsible to bring it
together
and alive and nod
we'll shake his head
but uh i think that's that because
certainly um
the corporate manager for communities
when we spoke
i the impression i was left with that
was going to be one of the things that
we were going to concentrate on
particularly with the new assistant
director of health and well-being being
very very keen
on that system
who the corporate manager for
communities
reports to
that's my understanding jim
is is that something that we could put
in our recommendation
that we
we will ask
i think we need to ask the cabinet
member to look into it we can't really
we can't give in instruction to
to officers but we can ask the cabinet
the appropriate cabinet member yeah um
so is that something council flatman
that you would yes certainly i'm i've
got a cabinet meeting today later on so
i'll bring all these points up and um
councillor
councillor um
harry
forgot
richardson yeah richardson
harry harris richardson should be there
this afternoon so i can bring this up
because if nadeem did you speak to
nadine if um nadima's been talking about
this then harry probably knows anyway so
we'll have a little chat this afternoon
um that will that will certainly get it
raised at mid suffolk but we we need the
same same thing to be done at
uh at baber so
yes because chair we don't have an
equivalent of harry
on the
cabinet in um
labor so that would be derek wouldn't it
well derrick is the community's yeah
portfolio holder but i know harry
that we does health and
opposite yeah yeah so
that'll come under derek but at our next
community's um meeting we can bring this
all i can bring this all up and derek
will be there
well i think i think from this from this
meeting that it will go direct to the
two cabinet members as as a recommend as
a recommendation a request that they
look into this
so um it doesn't matter who the
the named cabinet we don't need to name
a cabinet member it will be a cabinet
member who will be asked to to look into
this
so
if we if we've left anything um unsaid
in there then i'm sure that the officers
will pick it up
um anyway we'll come back
at 11 11 40
at which time we may even have
something on the screen to be able to
have a look at
foreign
right we're back again and
we now have a set of recommendations
which are going to be read out by beth
the first block of recommendations
uh is for us all to vote on their joint
recommendations
to cabinet and others
we'll then take a vote on that
after that there will be
the recommendation
in respect of the mid suffolk
ca and then
the baba
one after that so we're going to have
three separate votes first one joint
second one mid suffolk third one weber
and
beth is going to read out
the the recommendations and then you'll
see on the screen that
we're voting for recommendations as read
by
the committee clerk
thank you chair
so the first lot of recommendations are
to thank the lca chief officers and
their respective staff for the work that
they have carried out in the last year
particularly during the pandemic
the committee are reassured that both
lca is operating effectively and
efficiently and responded well to all
questioning from members
that the councils take a single view of
debt and implement an integrated system
for dealing with housing rent and
council tax debt
that contact we made to food banks with
a request that their clients are
referred to the lca for advice on
nutrition and budgeting and concrete
skill classes
remote virtual operation capability for
lca and our body should be provided on
an accelerated program as a matter of
urgency defining locations iot equipment
and applications
training and connectivity
that cabinets be asked to consider the
previous resolution of joint overview
and scrutiny committee that the
three-year rolling funding arrangement
review be subject to indexation on an
annual review basis
and that the joint ovary and security
committee review local citizens advice
in december 2022
are you all content on that just one of
those and that's the one about the i.t
equipment i think that needs to be
headed up as a recommendation to cabinet
if it doesn't already say that
um so with with that i are you all
content
we need a proposal counselor casting i i
just wanted to um
ask the committee is everyone content
with looking at this on a yearly
basis or does anyone think that that
might be an overkill for
you know because obviously we've got to
manage our workload um i just thought
i'd bring that up i'm quite happy if no
one's got any concerns to um
go along with that that's that's the
only part of that that
i'd worry thank you councillor casper
that was my concern at the start before
we started the meeting and i've come
around to thinking that there is so much
that we've
discussed today that we really do need
them to come back for their benefit as
well as for hours in 12 months time and
they seem content to do that
yes
council field sorry
were you i was just going to make the
point that i thought
there's always value in these sort of
reports certainly the cab one is always
pretty competent to my view it gives you
a a clear view of what they're achieving
and you know the numbers of people the
the value for money so it is to my mind
one of the better reports that one sees
so i would have thought spending a bit
of the committee's time on it is
thank you valuable casa mclaren yes i
was going to support um that i mean i
was like you i thought we were
probably going to just
back off from it but in fact having
listened to that today i think it's very
relevant and i think we should review it
in a year's time
okay thank you
so
are we are we then content to vote on
that
block of
oh sorry we need we need a proposal
a councillor
seconded by councilman muller thank you
very much
the vote is now in progress and you
wouldn't talk about
he's told me i've got to log on again
counselors can have your vote verbally
and counselor barrett can have your vote
verbally as well
that's unanimous
thank you um
so we now move on to the recommendation
to mid suffolk cabinet please
so could that
could that now be read out please
the mid suffix recommendation is that
mid-suffolk cabinet are to confirm that
funding previously allocated to fredford
and this lca be allocated to
mid-southwark lca
so to have a proposal please counselor
scarf seconded by councillor muller
and
those who can can they vote
electronically
okay
thank you
cancer field could we just ask are we
instructing mid-suffocate
cabinet to confirm or asking them to
confirm or
it's a recommendation that we recommend
that mid-suffolk cabinet confirm cabinet
to confirm okay
yeah happy with that
yeah i
i'm i'm in favor i
still haven't managed to
so have you got votes from everybody now
yeah thank you that's five votes for and
that's unanimous thank you
council mclaren yes i'm looking at the
recommendation for
labour
um
i know it says enable greater provision
of debt advice but it's really for me i
have a concern about 50 of the district
that hasn't got access to
citizens advice provision is it
something we can
add in there or is it too late
no it's not too late would you like that
to to read
greater provision for debt advice across
the whole district
yes
yes across babro district yeah across
yeah it is a recommendation to buy the
cabinet so
my colleagues agree with that
yeah so the the new world is now on the
screen yeah
so
do i have a proposal then please
proposed by council mclaren and seconded
by
councillor barron thank you very much
and now the three of you can vote for
four against that
that's free votes for and that's
uniqueness thank you very much thank you
everybody um
right we just got one or two other items
left and
we now look at the baba and the
mid-south overview scrutiny work plans
does anyone have any comments please
these these work plans are for noting
only
if there are
if there are no comments
no we have none
uh council field
i noticed there's a topic land adoptions
policy
uh up there or there are several that
have not been yet scheduled
what sort of time frames are you
thinking of
[Applause]
um
the items the items not shared with
i was looking on page 16
yeah i was looking at 16. that's that's
the baber work plan which is almost
identical to the mid-separate work plan
yeah
um yes hi martin
um
well the land adoptions policy that was
in the program that dropped out because
the work hadn't progressed on the land
adoptions policy
that is going to come in as soon as
possible
the
stella marist review that's uh
that's a matter to a large degree for
the county council but as soon as there
is a date fixed
for that review then we will be putting
that
um
that will be considered for inclusion um
and
it could well it could well be that what
comes out of that review will feed into
items such as the scrutiny of
of
anti-social behavior projects and
policies as well
they are being looked at
following the
stella marriage report
we don't have
we don't have a time frame for
the review of
salt
um
we have asked for
um
the um a scrutiny of the way that
we communicate with cabinet and with
council and vice versa that
that is on hold at present pending
the potent well the report back to baby
district council on the possibility of
returning to the committee system or
some other form other than the cabinet
system
so
i'm not able at the minute to provide
you with any any details of when any of
those items
would be fitted into a program
we may be in a better position when we
meet
as two separate overview and scrutiny
committees in january to
to have some information on that
and also the other the other item is the
infrastructure delivery plan
which we will have to we'll have to
delay the scrutiny of of that pending
progress on the joint local plan
council
well just a general point joe obviously
part of our february meeting has been
cancelled already
because obviously
we won't hear
um
about the work on the infrastructure
delivery plan it now being pushed into
the long grass so it does appear to me
that the february joint meeting with
representatives on outside bodies which
we know
at best is a really difficult one for
scrutiny to deal with because we only
deal with the information that we get
from the representatives on outside
bodies and
quite often we don't actually get
information from them it it seems to me
that the february meeting is
you know going to be a very short
meeting so i wondered if the anti-social
behaviour won
because we've got consideration for it
between december
where we are now in february 2022 the
only place it can actually go is
february unless that date has to move
but is there something that we could
bring forward out of all of those things
to actually make the february meeting a
worthwhile meeting because i feel
if not
the february meeting in terms of
representatives and outside bodies might
might be better to be moved to a later
date and we cancel the meeting because i
can see
no point in having a meeting for what
will probably be a very short agenda
item one of the other things we've got
is the
improved access to the private rented
sector uh and it says that chairs are
going to discuss the timing for bringing
this to committee i mean this has been
on the forward plan
for some time i mean even if we had an
information bulletin or something like
that uh rather than a full debate on it
perhaps that would make a february
meeting more worthwhile coming to
members today we've only dealt with one
major item
and it's probably good that we've only
dealt with one major item because it
took a very long time to deal with it
and quite rightly so but i'm just
concerned about the length of the
meeting or the necessary need for a
meeting if we don't have enough business
to actually transact and the fact that
you know as you've mentioned we haven't
got time scales for a lot of these
things that are coming forward so i
think it is a problem that the the two
chairs of the joint committees will have
to tackle between you and i know that
you will um you know ensuring that we've
actually got a full
uh program of work otherwise overview
and scrutiny isn't really carrying out
this function
yes uh council staff the other the other
possibility is that there might be
an initial report from the task of
finnish group
and to looking into rural transport
in february but that
that's by no means certain um but i
think the feeling perhaps is that
if we can't bring something forward and
we can't have an initial report from
that task and finish group that perhaps
we really should give consideration to
uh
not having that meeting but to have
the
representatives on outside bodies
added on to the march meeting which is
also a joint meeting castle baron
thank you um an area i'd like to
add on to uh the list is
um the cost of maintenance to our
tenanted properties which has risen
enormously
in the lockdown perhaps understandably
but what i'd like to to sort of look at
is
perhaps bring it to the community to
look at the the factors and to ensure
that um
that is all consistent with the big
circumstances of the and
pandemic
um
just going back to you points about the
infrastructure delivery plan
i think you'd said in an earlier
discussion that that was about
county council infrastructure
am i right
well they have an input into the
infrastructure delivery plan the
infrastructure delivery plan includes
all sorts of things
including
improvements to railway stations highway
improvements and new and new and new or
extended
schools but of course the money is
connected collected through sales so
any expenditure
has to go through i think it's through
cabinet
i'll be corrected if i'm wrong but for
there to be expenditure
on um say a new school or a school
extension
that comes before the district council's
cabinet does it not yeah
so the district councils have a role in
that
um
i'm not sure that it's an area that we
can add any
value to
or if all we are
uh
checking is that it meets with um the
seal criteria
that is very set up very uh well
established
um
is that really something that we can
provide any
greater
you know benefit
to the council by by looking at
um
she'll show this
my co-chair and ask myself take that
away and have a look to see um
tom barker has asked for a discussion
about about delaying that i think he was
he was preparing to to come to us with a
report but we could go back to him
see what see what there is that we might
be able to influence and if it is very
literal or nothing at all then
we'll come with a recommendation that we
dropped that one
um sorry the first one you talked about
was the
um
the the cost
um of maintaining our properties
would it be appropriate to have an
information bulletin in the first
instance on that um
you rightly say that the cost has gone
up there are a number of factors
involved in that
and it might be useful to have an
information bulletin to explain that and
and perhaps to to
offer
some
not exactly a prediction of how that's
going to pan out in the future
but to have a for the officers to have a
forward look on whether that's something
that will continue whether it will level
off or
or indeed
prices will will drop back again
so would you be content if we put an
information bullet yeah sure i'll bow to
your your knowledge of how this process
might work so if that if you think that
the the um the committee can can look at
that initially then yes that might be
the bet the first option to to look at
so i think it's worthwhile us having
some information on it um and then on
the basis of the information bulletin we
can determine whether or not there's a
further piece of work to do
but without the information i think
you're quite right it's worth some
something worth knowing about
and potentially working on
if we can
bring that in february we'll have the
february meeting
particularly if we can bring an initial
report from the task of finish group
if neither of those is a possibility
then we will look to
bring the
representation on outside bodies to the
following meeting
council mclaren
yes chair
just
my suggestion of the review of south
would the same apply to that because
it's obviously an external body would an
information bulletin be helpful to the
committee
initially
um
because i wonder if because there are so
many people involved in it we we might
approach that by our witnesses rather
than
i think we if we were going to review
sulk there's some work for officers to
do
okay but then i think we would need we
would need to hear firsthand
the views of parish councils town
councils okay
and so on
council field
can i just ask what influence one might
have over south i mean they're part of
the national association of local bodies
such bodies aren't they
and they don't report to the district
council or the county council in any
particular way although we're invited i
just wonder what we are
imagining we're going to achieve
um
i think the feeling
i mean yes i understand that i think the
feeling was that they carry out training
which
um
there seems to be no vetting of the
training that they give
um they carry out some training on
topics that the district council has in
the past um for instance planning
training which
historically we received from planning
officers and now as
parish councils we we receive that from
um from south or through through salk
i think we needed to be assured that the
the quality of the training that they
give
is
is satisfactory
council mclaren i just answer council of
field please do
that
there seems to be some gaps
council of field and
when i brought it up i think we spoke to
the monitoring officer
it was felt that if we identify gaps it
may not be salt that has to provide it
but the district council
because there are some gaps in the
system that are happening and that was
my reason for raising it thank you
yes and i think i think that some parish
councils feel that they they don't have
access to the training that they need in
order to be parish councillors
so i think there is a piece of work
there
uh
councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman
being a a chairman of the baber group of
selk i can assure you that uh
all those
projects that are brought forward by
sell to parish councils are for them to
use and they
if they choose not to use them it's up
to them but they have full
uh they have a full agenda of what they
can provide for them i can assure you
that
thank you
monitoring officer
thank you and chair i just wanted to
pick up the point about um this sort of
scrutiny of external or third-party
bodies because i think we've we have
talked about it before um but just to
make it clear that the committee can
look into other authorities they can
look into other public sector or
charitable sector organizations but you
have no statutory power over them so
they can choose not to engage
with the process or um they they might
engage but then choose not to follow any
recommendations that come out of the
review
i think actually what you're really
talking about is a look at
the support that's available to parish
councils and how they get advice and how
they get training and how they get
support for perhaps some really complex
issues that parish councils do
face
and i think that's less about
scrutinizing salk but looking at the
bigger picture of which salk is a part
of that support framework so i think
it's perhaps wider than just reviewing
what the self provides but it's more
about um you know looking at the the
whole
whole package of support that parish
councils can access and whether that's
sufficient for what they need thank you
chair
thank you it does sound rational i must
admit
i was just having
sal was within what was my county
division and no longer is and one was
fairly familiar with what they got up to
and this distinct feeling that they
believe that they do about better jobs
than probably
certain other local
authorities like perhaps our good selves
it's just interesting to wonder where it
was going and you've made that clear
thank you
thank you are there any other comments
on the work plans the work plans are for
noting
so thank you very much for that
i believe we've come to the end of our
agenda
so
we that concludes the the meet this
meeting the next mid-suffolk
overview and scrutiny meeting will be on
the 13th of january
at 9 30 and the next baba overview of
scrutiny meeting will be on the 16th of
january
at 9 30. thank you
you